une piste à obstacles au pied de la tour
olympique de montréal alors quand je
vois des planchistes avant il n'y avait
pas vraiment d'option dans la ville
factice hors de la ville ghana la saint
bruno à saint sauveur à bromont récit
culture un accès pour tout le monde
c'est gratuit
cette nouvelle piste se trouvent sur les
lieux mêmes de l'ancienne piste de ski
morgen très populaire au siècle dernier
avec son remonte pente est aussi sa
grande histoire en bois ya plus d'une
centaine d'années ben et les jeunes se
donner rendez vous ici sur la côte
morgan et pour pratiquer les sports de
glisse ce projet a été réalisé grâce à
un partenariat entre la fondation céline
aux jo la compagnie vannes canada et le
pas connecté
hélène charles et la mère de dylan aux
jo un jeune planchiste montréalais de 22
ans mort accidentellement en 2018
quelqu'un qui est un planchiste d'avoir
ça dans sa ville accueille ses amis
peuvent participer
et de serre
un rêve de parents pendant notre enfance
entre autres avec des experts pour le
design du parc
c'est sûr que ce soit un support qui
peut comporter certains dangers mais
c'est obligatoire de mettre un casque
chez terra il faut s'écouter là dedans
pour offrir à notre est une autre belle
occasion d'aller jouer dehors à ces
temps de pandémie moi je pense que d'ici
là on est confiné chez nous on peut
vraiment sortir et que ça permet aux
jeunes de prendre appui de socialiser
aussi surtout
issigeac bissonnet radio canada montréal